effectivement jean piat sur votre
réaction est bien cette décision qui a
été prise par le bureau du sénat de
transmettre à la justice notamment bien
sûr les cas d'alexis colère patrick
strzoda et du général lavernhe c'est
pour voir motifs de satisfaction
certainement pas un motif de
satisfaction
je dirais que c'est une décision qui est
totalement logique
nous avons fait un rapport ce n'est pas
forcément gagné d'avancé jean pierre
sueur mais j'étais toujours confiant
quant à la logique du sénat pourquoi
voulez vous qu'on change d'avis nous
avons campagne oui mais nous avons fait
un rapport pourquoi nous l'avons nous
fait parce que nous sommes nous avons
été constituée en commission d' enquête
parlementaire
qu'est ce que dit la constitution
article 51 alinéa 2 les commissions d
enquête parlementaire contrôler le
gouvernement évalue les politiques
publiques
nous on était dans notre rôle il y a eu
d'immenses dysfonctionnements très grave
avec monsieur banal à monsieur kraz et
nous c'est impossible que ça se
fonctionne comme ça en plus haut niveau
de l'état dont nous avons reçu beaucoup
de personnes non nées son affaire des
faux témoignages qui ont témoigné et
quand on est devant une commission
denquête parlement tire terre qui
conçoit on doit juré de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité
est-ce que vous jugez que les hauts
fonctionnaires vous ont menti autant que
vincent kra z emballages de vire au fait
le distinguo entre annick strzoda d'une
part et les deux autres de palmarès je
dis que quand un haut fonctionnaire
arrive qu'on lui pose la question
monsieur benalla exerce cette île des
missions de sécurité qu'ils nous
répondent non et qu'après nous
produisons quantité de documents
à commencer par la fiche de poste dans
le port d'armes etc
des témoignages qui montrent que c'est
faux eh bien c'est faux ce n'est pas la
vérité c'est tout et nous nous sommes là
pour connaître la vérité donc nous avons
fait beaucoup d'auditions elles ont
toutes été public c'est à dire que tous
les français ont pu voir notre travail
après nous avons publié un rapport pour
dire voilà c'est la vérité selon nous
voilà les dysfonctionnements très grave
et voilà les mesures que nous
préconisons pour que ça ne recommence
pas que répondez-vous à la république en
marche on entend déjà et bien la
république en marche qui dit c'était un
procès politique dont l'issue était
connue d'avancé mais c'est faux et moi
vous savez eux
quand j'entends ça je me sens insulté
humilié
je pense qu'on ne respecte pas qu'on dit
que je fais de la politique politicienne
que j'ai un a priori qui est un a priori
politique mais pourquoi j'aurai un a
priori contre la république en marche
c'est un parti démocratique qui joue son
rôle j'ai beaucoup d'amis à la
république engage beaucoup donc pourquoi
on me fait ce procès il ya aucune raison
j'ai fait un travail vous comprenez là
où ça n'a pas marché c'est l'assemblée
nationale où comme la commission des
lois et est présidée par quelqu'un de la
république en marche annoncée pour des
raisons de politique là la famille dans
l action est vraiment ensemble on
demande des instructions mais nous
n'avons demandé aucune instruction nous
sommes des parlementaires de toutes les
sensibilités politiques dans la
commission des lois
constituant commission denquête nous
avons fait notre travail et nous avons
publié un rapport et âme
je vous le dis tout ce qu'ils ont lu ce
rapport voir qu'il n'ya rien de faux
dans le rapport et même le gouvernement
les membres aux innombrables enfin
parfois ils ont répondu ils n'ont rien
répondu
et il n'y a pas une seule personne ni
dans le gouvernement ni dans la majorité
qui a dit qu'une seule affirmation de
notre rapport était fausse donc ce
rapport il est totalement vrai un mot
sur la contre campagne qu'il ya eu
notamment de la part des centristes pour
justement aller à l'encontre de vos
préparations avec marseille qui dit il
ya une alliance de circonstance entre
les verts et les socialistes je ne suis
pas dans cette mission enquête en tant
que socialiste que l air que rem que je
ne sais pas que le communisme non
je suis là en tant qu'un parlementaire
qui avec d'autres parlementaires
applique la constitution est-ce qu'on
veut que dans ce pays il y ait un
pouvoir de contrôle du parlement
si on veut qu'il n'y ait pas de pouvoir
de contrôle du parlement qu'on le dise
mais alors on va être dans une drôle de
république ça va pas être dans notre
tradition et cl aux pouvoirs de contrôle
est exercé par des parlementaires
ce sont des parlementaires qui ont tous
une étiquette politique
mais ils sont pas là au nom de leur
étiquette politique combien de fois
votre attire le dire à monsieur
marseille qui qui dit voilà c'est la
collusion mais c'est pas du tout la
pollution nous sommes des parlementaires
nous faisons notre boulot de
parlementaires qui est de rechercher la
vérité nous l'avons fait et alors
aujourd'hui que voulez-vous que disent
le bureau il n'allait pas contredire un
rapport que le gouvernement n'a pas
contredit que l'om n'a pas contredit la
seule chose qui nous est dit c est un
problème de séparation il nous a été dit
un problème de séparation du pouvoir
mais il n'y a pas de problème lisez
l'article 51 alinéa de l article 24 de
la constitution
il n'y a aucun problème de ces aucun
problème donc nommé donc je suis très
clair notre problème c'est la vérité est
ce qu il faut d commission d' enquête
indépendante composée de gens de divers
partis politiques mais on n'est pas là
pour faire de la politique politicienne
merci c'est très important pas de
politique politicienne merci beaucoup et
jean pierre jean n'avoir repéré à mes
questions